i'm now ready to explain
how
coin flipping will help us to arrive to
a soft k-means clustering calgary
we already saw how to interpret the
data parameters and hidden vector in the
case of k-means clustering in this case
data is actually a set of data points
parameters is the set of centers and
hidden vector is simply assignment of
data points to centers
now we want to transform this hidden
vector into hidden matrix and for this
specific hidden vector this
transformation is travel this is a
hidden matrix corresponding to this
hidden vector
but we want now to design arbitrary
hidden matrices for example hidden
matrix where the responsibility for the
first data point
will be distributed between the first
second and third centers so something
like this
the question remains how can we derive
such hidden
matrices it turns out there are a few
ways to derive
hidden matrices in the case of k-means
clustering problem and we start from the
hidden matrix motivated by the law of
gravitation in this case the interpret
centers as stars and interpret data
points as planets
and responsibility of a star for a
planet is proportional to the pool
defined by the newtonian law of
gravitation or in other words the force
that
star i
exert on the planet j is defined as 1
divided by square distance between this
planet and star
and we define hidden matrix based on
these derived forces
it turns out that even better
responsibilities
can be derived by using
an inspiration from statistical
mechanics in this point
responsibility of center i for a data
point j will be proportional to
e
to the power
minus better
distance between a data point and center
where beta is a stiffness parameter and
we defined hidden matrix exactly in the
same way as was shown at the previous
slide
this slide shows that heart k-means
clustering
produces different results and soft came
in clustering and moreover parameter
better stiffness parameter for soft
gaming clustering may significantly
affect clustering result and that is why
the soft of
adequate
stiffness parameter is important in
various bioinformatics applications for
clustering
and we are almost done with coverage of
clustering calgary in the last section i
will talk about yet another approach to
clustering which is called hierarchical
clustering